[Musique]
merci je ressens prix merci mesdames et
messieurs membre du conseil de la
fédération les députés de la douma
d'état mesdames et messieurs les
citoyens de la fédération de russie
cette adresse a lieu pour la première
fois au début de l'année
nous n'avons pas de temps pour résoudre
les problèmes économiques et sociales
qui se posent devant notre pays ses
repères sont définis pas dans des
projets nationaux qui exige la qualité
de la gestion et le travail de tous les
niveaux des autorités un dialogue direct
avec les citoyens
aujourd'hui dans notre société il y à la
demande des transformations
les gens veulent le développement ils
veulent progresser dans leur métier dans
leur bien-être
ils sont prêtes à assumer la
responsabilité pour des actes concrets
très souvent ils savent mieux qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer qu'est-ce qu'il faut
transformer sur place dans les villes
dans les villages partout dans le pays
les rythme de ces changements doivent
être augmentées avec des résultats
tangibles pour chacun pour atteindre le
niveau de vie décent avec je répète la
participation active des citoyens
mesdames et messieurs le sort de la
russie dépend du nombre des habitants
dans notre pays et je voudrais commencer
justement par la démocratie démographie
combien d'enfants vont être dans les
familles russes dans un an dans cinq ans
dans dix ans quel serait le sort de ces
enfants ce qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire pour
l'avenir de notre pays et quelles sont
les valeurs propres à ses enfants
aujourd'hui nous sommes 147 millions
d'habitants mais nous avons entamé la
période assez difficile du point de vue
démographique et grâce aux mesures que
nous avons entrepris depuis le milieu
des années 2000 nous avons obtenu des
résultats positifs et nous avons atteint
l'accroissement naturel de la population
il ya plus d'écoliers
mais les familles ne sont pas nombreuses
c'est la génération des années 90 et il
y à la baisse du taux de notre natalité
si là il y a un problème
le coefficient du taux de natalité c'est
à dire le nombre de naissances par femme
a constitué 1,5
est-ce que c'est peu ou bien c'est
beaucoup c'est peu pour notre pays c'est
un peu les 10 et propres aux pays
européens mais c'est peu pour la russie
pour comparer un vaguelettes 3 c'était
l'an 10 en 1943 en pleine guerre mais
dans les années 90 c'était encore pire
par exemple dans les os il y avait avec
les 16 en 1999 pire qu'au cours de la
guerre les familles n'ont procédé rare
et je répète ses prévisions négatives
nous préoccupe beaucoup c'est pourquoi
notre devoir historique et d'assumer
cette responsabilité et donc éviter ce
piège des mots trafic et donc stabilisée
l'accroissement naturel de la population
en russie en 2024
nous devons obtenir cet indice au niveau
de 1 da que les 7es
et nous avons besoin de décisions
propres nous avons besoin des programmes
publics et ces programmes doivent être
évaluées geipan de vue de la priorité
nationale
c'est à dire augmenter la population de
la russie
nous devons construire la politique
familiale
sur la base des situations concrètes et
voir les difficultés auxquelles font
face les familles nombreuses revient les
familles non complète par exemple le
problème qui existe tant voyez un enfant
au jardin d'enfants nous avons débloqué
des crédits pour créer deux cent
cinquante cinq mille places dans les
jardins d'enfants et dans les crèches
mer au lieu de 90 mille places
nous avons un créé seulement 78 et sert
assez peu mais pour le moment il n'y a
pas de licence pour d'autres places
c'est à dire que ces établissements ne
sont pas prêtes à accueillir les enfants
mesdames et messieurs les responsables
des entités fédérées
il ne faut pas travailler comme ceci
cela veut dire que nous avons créé 77
vert que les 7000 mais qui ne sont pas
opérationnelles puisque la moitié ne
peut pas accueillir des enfants
mais ici à 2021
nous devons créer encore cent soixante
dix sept heures que de trois places
il faut faire il faut combler ce retard
et je répète qu'il faut soutenir les
familles
mais il y à la menace démographique pour
notre avenir
ce sont les revenus très basse de
nombreuses familles environ 70 ou 90 %
de familles qui ont des revenus bas ce
sont des familles qui ont des enfants
même quand les deux parents travaillent
les revenus sont assez modestes et nous
avons donc pris des décisions depuis
janvier de l'année dernier jeu les
familles seront soutenus puisque nous
allons subventionner le premier enfant
est le deuxième enfant jusqu'à trois ans
et cela dépend dieu minimum vital dans
la région et il s'agit donc en moyenne
de montant de 11 mille euros blé et à
part cela soutenu par le budget fédéral
nous allons soutenir encore le troisième
et le quatrième enfant dans soixante
quinze entités fédérales à l'oral en
sibérie et en extrême orient
c'est le grand soutien de l'état mais je
pense sur ceux ci
quand l'enfant atteint 3 en 1
l'état arrête les subventions et donc la
famille se retrouve en difficulté ce qui
se passe sur place c'est inacceptable et
je comprends très bien que tant que
l'enfant est né pas scolarisés la femme
a de la peine à concilier le travail et
l'éducation des enfants et les enfants
tombent souvent malades et je propose
donc de prévoir les subventions
mensuelles pour les enfants de 3 à 7 ans
y compris l'âge de 7 ans
[Applaudissements]
depuis le 1er janvier de l'année 2000
avant que ce lac sera concerné par cette
mesure de soutien
ces subventions seront destinés à ceux
qui n'ont pas de minimum vital pour
chaque membre de famille et pourraient
être subventionnées il serait suffit de
adressé une déclaration est d'indiquer
votre revenu et je voudrais que cette
procédure soit simple et commode pour
que les citoyens aient la possibilité de
passer toutes les formalités au bien
passer par des services à distance dans
chaque entité fédérée donc comme je les
dis les revenus peuvent être différents
et les subventions vont constituer la
moitié du minimum vital 5,5 milles euros
blanc mais on va évoluer comme en
fonction de ce système et si on va voir
que certaines familles ne peuvent pas
bénéficier de ce soutien on va
entreprendre une autre démarche et on va
donc
dans chaque entité fédérée subventionner
la famille à la hauteur du minimum vital
c'est à dire 11 mai roblet par ben père
de famille
les chiffres seront différents par en
fonction de l'enquêté fédérale mais en
moyenne ce sera onze mille roubles pour
réaliser cette mesure nous avons besoin
des ressources financières de corriger
le budget fédéral et je demande le
gouvernement russe de le faire de façon
opérationnelle et bien sûr les régions
vont travailler là dessus
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire de façon très
rapide dans l'adresse de l'année
dernière j'ai parlé du contrat social 1
ce contrat social ces en sorte le
programme personnel pour augmenter la
qualité de vie de chaque famille
dans le cadre de ce contrat social
l'état subventionne les membres de
famille
il s'agit de par exemple de la formation
professionnelle ou bien de créer sa
propre entreprise petites entreprises et
bien sûr la société et que le
gouvernement attend de ce genre des
démarches qui vont dans la recherche du
métier est bien assuré assumer la
responsabilité face à face à nos enfants
pour le moment l'efficacité de ce
contrat social n'est pas très grande et
l'impact est minime et donc je demande
le gouvernement d'évaluer l'expérience
de ce contrat social est aussi élargir
le soutien financier des régions pour
que en 2021 implanter ce mécanisme dans
toutes les entités fédérées
et je porte votre attention chers
collègues
les responsables de régions sur les
résultats ce n'est pas le nombre de
contrats sociaux mais la réduction de la
pauvreté et la réduction réelle en 2006
dans l'adresse à l'assemblée fédérale
j'ai proposé j'ai dit à l'époque comme
ceci maintenant le principal l'amour et
j'ai proposé donc le programme du
capital de maternité l'objectif de ce
programme c'est d'aider les familles qui
ont pris la décision d'avoir le deuxième
enfant
ce programme est prévue pour le 31
décembre 2021 et les gens demandaient
qu'est ce qu'il est ce que le
gouvernement l'état va faire au delà de
cette échéance nous allons prolonger ce
programme de capitale de maternité au
minimum d'ici jusqu'à 31 décembre 2020 6
cette démarche est obligatoire
ce n'est pas suffisant aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de soutenir les jeunes
familles
ceux qui commencent leur vie familiale
qui rêve d enfant et donc je propose des
décisions complémentaires dans le cadre
du capital de maternité qui vont entrer
en vigueur depuis le 1er janvier 2020
avec la naissance du premier enfant à la
famille accède au droit au capital de
maternité pleinement
et après l'indexation le montant va
constituer 466 617 roubles ce montant
était prévue pour le deuxième en forme
et ce soutien va permettre à la famille
de
se préparait pour la naissance du
deuxième enfant
mais ce n'est pas suffisant il faut
faire plus et je propose d'augmenter le
capital de maternité de 150 mille
roubles le droit à ce montant
la famille va avoir au moment de la
naissance du deuxième enfant et le
montant total du capital de maternité va
constituer donc 6 et 616 1617 roblin et
donc ce montant va être intégrée chaque
année et je considère que si la famille
à un enfant
déjà après la naissance du deuxième
enfant
ce capital de maternité on va être
calculée calculé pour le montant de 616
1617 roblin et je vais acheter que nous
avons déjà pris la décision que au
moment de la naissance du troisième
enfant le l'étape et 450 mille roubles
du crédit immobilier et donc la famille
qui a trois enfants j'ai investir donc
le l'immobilier plus d'un million de
roubles pour un nombre de régions russes
des villes des grandes villes même c'est
presque la moitié d'une maison où vient
d'un appartement et se tournent de
crédit immobilier préférentiels qui est
6% et c'est le taux dont bénéficie tout
le crédit immobilier et donc nous avons
augmenté de 10 fois le nombre de
familles qui bénéficient de ces taux
nous à l'extrême orient ce ton constitué
même 2% et je demande les banques de
participer à ce programme préférentiel
est encore une question
j'ai évoqué la subvention pour les
enfants de 3 à 7 ans
mais ce n'est pas tout ce que nous
pouvons faire 1,8
quand l'enfant va à l'école les parents
ont plus de possibilités de travailler
et avoir des revenus complémentaires
mais les dépenses des familles pour une
enfant scolarisé son plus grand de il y
a plus de préoccupations et à cette
étape nous avons besoin de soutenir les
familles et je propose de garantir le
repas gratuits pour les enfants qui vont
à l'école de la première classe à la
quatrième classe d'études
je ne cache pas il ya eu d'écran des
discussions et les collègues
certains collègues ne sont pas contre
mais et les disques ce n'est pas juste
puisque il y à des familles qui ont des
grands de revenus il y à des familles
assez modeste et et il ya une logique
mais il ya aussi une autre logique qui
est propre à notre société
tout le monde devrait se sentir dans des
conditions d'égalité
les enfants des familles modestes ne
peuvent pas se sentir lésés dans ce cas
et pour notre société c'est très
important
oui on me dit que même à l'époque
soviétique
avec tous ces programmes sociaux de
l'époque soviétique il n'y avait pas de
ce soutien social mais il n'y avait pas
de grandes disparités dans la société
soviétique comme aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est logique de le faire
aujourd'hui pour organiser ce repas
gratuit à l'école je propose de
d'employer les trois sources de
financement la société des râles locales
et régionales mais il faut créer une
infrastructure à l'école il faut des
réfectoires des cantines et bien sûr des
produits de qualité même à l'époque
soviétique il y avait des problèmes là
dessus et bien sûr cela nécessite du
temps mais dans les régions et dans les
écoles qui sont traites techniquement à
offrir ce repas gratuit il faut le faire
depuis le 1er septembre 2020 mais dans
toutes les régions dans toutes les
entités fédérées les enfants doivent
bénéficier de ce repas chaud gratuit en
général sa collègue est le sens de
toutes les décisions que nous prenons
ces degrés en russie un système efficace
et un système opérationnel du soutien
des familles pour que les revenus de nos
citoyens surtout de ceux qui élèvent des
enfants devrait être à la hauteur de la
vie digne et je répète les démarches que
nous avons entreprises
dans le social au social ont donné des
résultats et nous avons constaté qu' il
y à la génération qui est scolarisé
maintenant qu'ils entrent dans
l'université a des valeurs qui sont
propres à la famille c'est la mort c'est
le bonheur de maternité et de paternité
c'est le lien entre les générations
différentes
c'est le respect des personnes âgées ce
qu'ils ignorent la société ce qui donne
le sentiment de sécurité de fiabilité
si ces valeurs seront propres pour les
générations à venir
cela leur aidera dans leur vie adulte et
nous allons garantir le développement de
la russie en tant que grand pays un pays
qui est digne de ses valeurs chers
collègues le soutien de la famille aisée
ses valeurs c'est toujours s'adresser à
l'avenir aux générations qui devront
vivre à l'époque était un modifications
que le salon de ce léger les
technologiques cette année ça veut dire
en déterminer le sort de la russie aux
premiers siècles et pour que maintenant
même pourrait ouvrir leur potentiel il
faut que nous leur créons aider toutes
les conditions nécessaires et avant tout
il s'agit d'offrir à chaque enfant où
qu'il habite une bonne éducation de la
décennie à venir
en russie on aura à peu près 19 millions
l'écolier ce qui à 6 millions supérieur
à l'an disparaît de 2010 souvent on
entend dire qu'il est très compliqué de
à influencer les processus démographique
et à leur débloquer des grands au
montant au pour le moment au
démographique n'est pas raisonnable
alors on la pratique montre l'efficacité
de ses mesures de soutien de la famille
et le résultat est souvent supérieur à
nos attentes les plus courageuses je me
réjouis de ce fait de joie autant de
collier dans nos écoles
en même temps cette situation ne doit
pas dégrader le confort à la qualité de
l'éducation et je demande le
gouvernement et les régions au contenu
des facteurs démographiques et d'autres
facteurs de déterminer combien il nous
faut d'une place supplémentaire aux
écoles il faut amender le projet
national d'éducation
là il faut trouver des solutions
flexibles non seulement construire des
écoles mais profiter avec efficacité de
toute infrastructure existante dans le
domaine éducatif les faut profiter des
coupelles des possibilités offertes par
d autres technologiques modernes
maintenant puisque toutes les écoles de
la russie sont connectés à un réseau
internet en 2021
ces écoles doivent savoir l'accès haut
débit ce qui permettra d'aborder
pleinement la transformation numérique
et digitalisées des écoles nationales
pour assurer l'accès aux programmes les
plus les plus perfectionnés d'éducation
pour les professeurs et pour les
écoliers nous avons vu la croissance
dynamique développement des centres et
des pôles de formation technique pour
les enfants il faut faire de même pour
les arts pour la peinture au sens du
projet national la culture ont débloqué
à plus de 8 milliards de roubles pour
ajuster l'équipement musical pour les
écoles de musique quand le problème plus
large a maintenant nous voyons que plus
d'un millier d'établissements pareil a
occupé des bâtiments vétustes
je demande des régions de m à l'ordre
dans ce domaine c'est votre obligation
et votre responsabilité
ensuite l'école moderne
c'est un professeur annonce tuteur
moderne en enseignant moderne et le fort
offrir le prestige national à ce métier
d'ici quelques années les possibilités
de croissance de carrière doit être
offert à tous les professeurs des écoles
surtout dans le domaine de
l'enseignement supplémentaires
professionnels ce travail quotidien lié
avec l'éducation et l'instruction des
enfants c'est une grande responsabilité
et ce travail nécessite une formation
supplémentaire particulière des
instituteurs et leur foi offrir du sud y
en a 7 et guerre je crois important de
données en supplément aux professeurs
des écoles responsable des classes au
niveau de 5000 roubles au profit du
budget fédéral
ce plaisir là aussi a fait couler
d'encre parce que c'est celle
obligations les responsabilités des
régions mais nous comprenons que le
blanc si j'étais responsable de la case
études c'est plutôt celui qui
responsable d'un grand nombre d enfants
et c'est le niveau international et je
te prêter votre attention à ce que
toutes les mesures prises et d'avant se
doivent de conserver tous les
suppléments salariales doivent être
conservés et je vais le contrôler j'ai
plusieurs fois à prêter votre attention
à ce que tous les paramètres des
salaires des employés militaires décédés
salariés doivent être respectés
strictement je m'adresse sur ce sujet
c'est pas par hasard si nous perdons le
contrôle de cette question et je pense
que vous êtes d'accord avec moi on est
toujours tenté de négliger ce sujet il
s'agit des spécialistes et qui sont
employées dans les domaines les plus les
plus importantes de la vie sociale et
leur travail doit être viande payé
les écoliers vont être plus nombreux à
être formé des écoles alors il faut leur
offrir la possibilité de voir
l'enseignement supérieur à ce sujet je
propose d'augmenter la quantité les à
bours et gratuité dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et je vous demande de les offrir
prioritairement aux établissements
régionaux surtout privilégier les
territoires où nous avons ces
déficiences des médecins des
instituteurs à des ingénieurs
il est évident qu on peut pas se limiter
à augmenter les quantités des étudiants
avec la participation du business il
faut à améliorer le niveau
d'enseignement améliorer
l'infrastructure éducative et technique
il faut prêter attention à la formation
professionnelle continue d un professeur
pour offrir la possibilité aux étudiants
d'aujourd'hui d'être embauchée dans le
région le marché de travail et un
changement continu les émissions
disparaissez et on en voit apparaître
d'autres il faut réagir rapidement à ces
modifications je crois qu'il est
important d'offrir aux étudiants après
la deuxième année d'étude la possibilité
de réorienter leurs études
c'est pas aussi simple que ça mais c'est
important pour offrir aux jeunes leaders
la possibilité de de réussir nous avons
a lancé le concours national des leaders
dans lequel la plus de 3,5 millions de
jeunes ont déjà participé l'année passée
à l'espérance de vie en russie a dépassé
60 présent ses habitants supérieur de
e par rapport à l'année 2000 c'est le
résultat de la modifie des changements
dans le pays du développement au des
sports de masse et les pv dans que le
système de santé public et a fait une
contribution considérable en lève le pan
le système de soin médical technologique
en protégeant la maternité la natalité
le niveau de la mortalité enfantine a
connu en mini membre historique c tandis
chesneau est meilleur qu dans certains
pays européens
je suis au courant au cul la société
dans de nombreux pays développés souvent
critiqués pour leur système de santé
publiques respectives
parce que dans tous presque dans tous
les pays les citoyens critiques et leurs
systèmes de santé publique aussi bien
que ce que ça paraisse à de l'extérieur
mais quand on nous ce que nous avons su
offert dans ce domaine nous prouve
encore une fois qu une fois l'objectif
fixé ne sommes capable de l'atteindre
mais il est évident que dans le domaine
de la santé publique ne se sont pas les
chiffres et les indices statistiques qui
sont importantes
quelqu'un qu'il doit à faire une grande
rencontre âgées pourra être récupérée
spécialiste médical
cette personne là ils s'intéressent pas
beaucoup à la hausse de l'espérance de
vie dans le pays c'est sa propre vie son
pour ça pour toi santé qui les
intéressent il le veut avoir l'accès
sans entrave à la à l'assistance
médicale de qualité
alors maintenant il faut concentrer nos
efforts au niveau a à la médecine de
proximité
c'est là où nous avons en grand nombre
de points sensibles pour les gens durant
l'année en cours
comme c'était prévu dans le projet
national de santé nous devons à terminer
le déploiement de réseaux d un point des
deux médecins
mais ça veut pas dire que tous les
problèmes sont déjà rejoint les sens il
a pour la médecine
c'est non seulement de donner des des
prescriptions et envoyer les gens à
visiter les spécialistes à s'éloigner
l'essentiel c'est d'utiliser l'internet
haut débit le l'équipement au moderne
des plantes et je demande j'adresse je
m'adresse à au fond populaire de la
russie de contrôler ce problème on lance
les programmes de modernisation de la
médecine de proximité
nous allons rééquiper les polycliniques
les hôpitaux régionaux les au poste d
urgence dans toutes les régions du pays
et à ces fonds nous débloquons 500
milliards de roubles supplémentaires à
90% ce sont des ressources fédérales à
leur tour je demande les entités
fédérées de trouver les moyens pour
résoudre les problèmes d'hébergement des
médecins surtout dans les villages
éloignés
il faut profiter de toutes les
mécanismes existants y compris le
logement de service les questions de
formation des cadres et la question clé
pour la santé ne pourra santé publique
d'ici 2020 4 tous ces niveaux doivent
être remplis des spécialistes et avant
tout il faut travailler avec le les
services de proximité dans dont la
rentrée suivante
je demande de modifier les approches
pour aller à futurs étudiants mais 170%
doivent être bien ciblées
pour le pédiatre ce niveau doit
atteindre 75% l'écouta pour l'admission
ciblée du futur médecins doivent être
créées par les entités fédérées et qui
doivent garantir l'emploi aux étudiants
il faut assurer que les spécialistes
soit embûches et là où on en a besoin en
ce qui concerne la formation continue
des médecins il faut privilégier les
médecins avec le stage de travail dans
le la médecine de proximité
il faut le prévoir aussi pour les
centres hommes et du coup le niveau
fédéral à partir de cette année nous
allons à entamer en eau bois sistema de
salaire dans le système de santé publics
en fixant le taux fixe aux cent des
salaires et en utilisant tous les
supprimant or salariales qui ont testé
décidé je comprends que les réalisations
de toutes les mesures mentionnées exige
de grandes ressources
si vous revenez au point que j'ai pensé
le premier pour chaque point il faut
beaucoup d'argent alors je m'adresse au
gouvernement pour bien fixer les
priorités de notre développement
c'est notre avantage qui nous avons su
avoir durant les dernières années il
faut pas le perdre
je connais que dans plusieurs régions à
l'année passée on a eu des problèmes
avec à la livraison des médicaments aux
parfois les fonctionnaires avaient cette
approche la même que pour
de la bureautique mais c'est pas ça
c'est n'importe c'est important les
médicaments les gens ne doivent jamais
être en déficience et des médicaments
que leurs besoins qui rend cette année
nous allons lancer un nouveau registre
génériques des médicaments dans les gens
ont besoin ce qui permettra à livrer les
médicaments avec des fortes remises à
des gens qui en ont honte bue souvent
nous avons déjà adopté des décisions qui
permettrait à 2 d'importer des
médicaments d'une façon simplifiée opes
même les médicaments qui n'ont pas
encore une naissance sur le territoire
national je demande des fonctionnaires
de faire tout au pour que les gens
surtout les familles qui ont besoin des
médicaments ne souffre pas de leur
absence sur le territoire national nous
allons modifier le contrôle de la
qualité des médicaments en le renforçant
non seulement à lalandusse crime et à
toutes les étapes de leur circulation y
compris dans les réseaux des pharmacies
chers collègues ces dernières années
nous allons concert nous avons
concernant focaliser nos efforts à
renforcer à l'économie nationale budget
fédéral et d'un profit science notre
ressource une ressource en subtilisant
de couvrir la dette extérieure il s'agit
pas des chiffres inventés ce sont les
chiffres qui sont directement liés avec
la vie quotidienne de chaque citoyen
avec le remplacement de nos obligations
sociales envers le citoyen nous voyons
quels problèmes aux quels problèmes sont
confrontés les citoyens des pays qui
n'ont pas eu ce coup sans de sécurité
économique est la suite à à la politique
qui est consécutive de la banque
centrale et du gouvernement
3 % d'inflation durant l'année passée ce
qui est inférieur à 4 % à la limite est
fixée la hausse de prix pour certains
cas de catégorie des marchandises a été
un peu supérieur mais l'inflation est
assez basse ce qui a été prévu
la situation est tout à fait différente
à celle qu'on a témoigné il ya cinq 5
ans par exemple lorsque l'inflation à
deux chiffres c'était une sorte d'impôt
à cucq en cours et certains certaines
catégories de la population surtout les
salariés maintenant en me basant ce
fondement économique est stable nous
devons créer les conditions pour
l'augmentation des revenus des citoyen
c'est la mission primordiale du
gouvernement de la banque centrale il
faut modifier la structure de l'économie
nationale pour en renforcer l'efficacité
en 2000 devant l'ex la cadence eu de
hausse de pib de la russie qui doivent
être aussi doit être supérieur à des
indices moyens dans le monde
il faut augmenter les investissements à
la rénovation des postes de travail des
emplois au développement de l'industrie
de l'agriculture du secteur tertiaire
le niveau d'investissements de nouveau
s'élever à 5 % et cela part dans le pb
doit être augmentée de vente et en %
jusqu'à 25% d'ici 2020 4 alors qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour et stimuler les
investissements
tout d'abord un an sont convenus de
n'est pas modifié les conditions
fiscales là pour le business diront les
cercles les six ans à venir ce qui
permettra aux deux hommes d'avoir le
raison de planification plus large pour
les milieux d'affaires
nous allons adopter les lois des antes à
protéger les investissements les
conditions fiscales pour le grand projet
doivent être modifiées à bhl pour le
délai de vente en et l'exigence des
normes
voilà produit à la construction des
sites industriels doivent êtres fixés
pour trois ans à venir
toutes ces conditions doivent être
adoptés se forme de joie et les
évidences que le groupe business n'est
pas seul à avoir besoin de soutien il
faut se tenir à les petites et moyennes
entreprises
nous avons déjà des mesures a par
exemple les privilèges fiscaux
la déduction fiscale l'acquisition pas
toujours utilisés parce que ça concerne
la réduction des recettes fiscales des
régions alors alors je propose à aux
frais du budget fédéral compenser les
deux tiers à des pertes de recette
fiscale des régions causés par les
déductions offertes aux entreprises chez
la fin de l'année on prévoit de terminer
la réforme des contrats ce qui va
simplifier les business
je demande de ma d'état a adopté les
amendements qui concerne à rendre plus
transparentes les à dossier du
tribunaux concernant les accusations
contre eux le business et j'ai pas porté
attention à l'oeuf au fameux article 210
du code pénal qui donnait la possibilité
de renforcer les responsabilités pénales
des gens qui travaillaient dans la même
entreprise a maintenant il faut faire de
manière que pour rembourser les
responsabilités pénales
les la police et le tribunal prouve que
l'entreprise est décrié à des fins
criminelles
nous avons créé les volumes des réserves
qui nous garantissent la fiabilité et la
sécurité
alors nos sont en mesure d'investir
davantage au développement de l'aic de
l'économie nationale
il faut privilégier l es obligé des
rendements y compris les routes de
contournement des grandes villes les
grandes routes les autoroutes entre les
à centrer juno ces projets vont causer
le la croissance de petites et moyennes
entreprises et l activité économique et
dans les régions
cinquième point hors cour la croissance
l'économie a besoin de l'argent de long
terme
et ça c'est l'argent si la
responsabilité directe de la banque de
russie
il faut rendre les crédits accessible
pour les entreprises du secteur réel de
l'économie
toutes les entreprises surtout les
grandes entreprises doivent à se
rappeler de leur responsabilité sociale
et je remercie les parlementaires pour
leur position stricte dans le domaine de
la protection de l'environnement et nous
allons adopter le système de supervision
de la qualité de l'air
ensuite nous allons reprendre cette
ce contrôle à tous les pays pour
contrôler l'état de l'air du sol est de
l'eau en bref en créant le système de
monitoring écologique vers la fin de
cette année au moins 80 entreprises
devront accéder aux décisions de
complexes écologiques pour réduire les
émissions dans l'atmosphère et pour le
moment nous avons délivré 16
autorisation pour cette technologie
il faut réduire le nombre de déchets il
faut accéder aux technologies qui
permettent de trier les déchets et
depuis l'année 2000 21,2 avoir le droit
à cette responsabilité écologique des
entreprises qui vont participer au
financement d
le tri des déchets c'est à dire ils vont
payer ce tri puisqu'il faut lui il faut
utiliser l'expérience des recherches
internationales dans la le domaine de
pollution de l'océan mondial de
l'environnement puisque il y à la
rapidité du développement des
technologies et nos devons adopter des
normes et des standards dans le domaine
de l'écologie dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle des nouveaux
matériaux et du numérique nous sommes
capables d'avoir à ses percées dans ce
domaine comme dans le domaine militaire
et pour résoudre ces missions nous
allons développer l'infrastructure de
recherche y compris les installations de
mega science il faut donc stimuler les
jeunes chercheurs
c'est comme ceux ci que que se passe et
chaque 2e chercheurs de notre pays sera
plus jeune que l'âge de 40 ans et c'est
notre objectif
ses soeurs ses ingénieurs ses
entrepreneurs doivent avoir la liberté
de recherche et je demande les députés
de l'assemblée fédérale 2 d'adopter des
lois dans ce sens et lancer un mécanisme
souple pour accéder aux nouvelles
technologies pour lancer la circulation
des métadonnées et à base des normes
internationales il faut mettre en place
le soutien public
de financement de recherche ces
chercheurs doivent avoir le droit au
risque puisque nous ne pouvons pas avoir
des règles qui ne permet pas de risque
et dans les recherches
il faut développer les entreprises
innovantes il faut développer les
exportations innovantes et soutenir la
demande pour des technologies nouvelles
il faut accélérer la transformation
numérique l'industrie et il faut faire
en sorte que les projets nationaux
soient basées sur les produits de
fabrication nationale à nous avons déjà
créé une grande infrastructure de la
télévision numérique de paresse et
performance et cette télévision est
parmi les plus modernes dans le mode
c'est plus élevé comme en france en
autriche ou bien en suisse et les gens
ont besoin aussi de l'internet la russie
est un rare pays qui possèdent des
réseaux sociaux nationaux des moteurs de
recherche nationaux d'autres ressources
internet et je propose de lancer un
projet internet accessible et donc à
garantir l'accès à l'internet 11 ans les
gens ne doivent pas payer pour le trafic
internet
chaque collègue
cette accessibilité de l'internet
devrait constituer notre à taux
compétitifs créer un milieu pour
l'éducation pour la communication et
pour réaliser des projets sociaux et
culturels
offrir des possibilités pour participer
à la vie
du pays chaque initiative est importante
elle initiatives des ong qui veulent
participer au développement national et
c'est très important
le bénévolat le mouvement des
volontaires qui intéresse les jeunes
c'est dire le poids se développe
il s'agit du respect par exemple envers
la génération des vétérans à la veillée
de la victoire dans la seconde guerre
mondiale
c'est très important nous sommes fiers
pour cette génération nous honorons ses
vétérans et nous pensons en entrée ligne
r nous sommes inspirés par ses
traditions et nous sommes obligés de
défendre la vérité sur cette victoire
dans la guerre il faut faire barrage aux
mensonges faire barrage aux tentatives
de transformer l'histoire et nous allons
créer l'archivage des documents
d'archivés qui parle de la grande guerre
patriotique la seconde guerre mondiale
accessible pour tout le monde
en russie et partout dans le monde et
c'est notre devoir
devant les générations à venir
[Applaudissements]
sa collègue nous voyons que l'évolution
dans le monde est imprévisible et ce qui
se passe au proche orient au moyen
orient en afrique pendant les dernières
semaines il ya eu beaucoup d'événements
nous avons vu comment les conflits
régionaux peuvent constituer la menace
pour l'humanité toute entière et je suis
certain que ce discours sur les normes
internationales qui peuvent garantir la
stabilité est nécessaire il faut faire
preuve de la volonté politique
j'ai du courage et nous devons assumer
la responsabilité dans l'international
et les pays confrontés les nations unies
devraient donner l'exemple les cinq pays
qui font partie des membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité
il faut commencer par les mesures qui
empêchent la nouvelle guerre il faut
développer les approches et qui
garantisse la stabilité sur la planète
tout en prenant en compte les aspects
militaires politiques culturelles et
sociales dans le monde
le récit est ouverte pour la coopération
avec tous les partenaires intéressés
nous ne menaçons personne nous
n'imposons notre volonté à personne mais
je vous assure que nos démarches qui
visent à garantir notre sécurité était
opportune et complète pour la première
fois je le souligne pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'armé nucléaire
y compris les kops l'époque soviétique
nous ne rattrapons personnes au
contraire les autres puissances autre
encore à créer une arme que la russie
possède déjà
[Applaudissements]
la capacité des forces de notre pays est
garanti pour quelques décennies dans
l'avenir mais il ne faut pas attendre il
faut progresser encore il faut évaluer
la situation dans le pays il faut
développer les systèmes d'armes dans
l'avenir ce que nous faisons puisque il
s'agit de notre sécurité et cela crée
les fondamentaux pour le développement
de notre pays
faire plus pour nos priorités nationales
il faut nous concentrer sur le la
croissance et économique la croissance
sociale de toutes les régions de la
russie puisque la grandeur de la russie
est indivisible de la vie digne de
chaque personne dans cette harmonie de
la grande russie
je vois la base de notre avenir en
progressant dans cette voie nous savons
besoin de la participation active de nos
citoyen de les situer société tout
entière et de toutes les proches du
pouvoir dont le potentiel demande à être
développé et je voudrais parler
également de la gestion publique de la
structure de la gestion dans notre pays
en on éprouve souvent des questions sur
la constitution russe y compris lors de
la conférence de presse récente
bien sûr la constitution a été adoptée
il y a environ vingt cinq ans dans le
contexte difficile de la crise interne
et les choses ont beaucoup évolué depuis
dieu merci nous n'avons pas de conflit
armé dans la capitale
nous n'avons pas de foyers de terrorisme
dans le caucase
malgré certains problèmes qui restent et
qui ne sont pas résolues
nous avons stabilisé la situation dans
le social et dans l'économie et un
nombre d'associations pose une question
sur l'adoption de la nouvelle
constitution
je ne vois pas la nécessité dans
l'adoption de la nouvelle constitution
puisque le potentiel de la constitution
de 93 n'est pas épuisé parce que les
bases fondamentales du régime
constitutionnel les droits de l'homme
vont être la base fiable pour notre
société russe cela dit et cette
discussion qui concerne certaines
changement modification de la
constitution se font entendre et je
crois qu'on peut parler de certains
amendements dans la constitution qui
sont un important en tant qu'un état
social est à l' état de droit qui a
comme valeur la dignité la liberté et
les droits de l'homme
première chose la russie veut rester la
russie en tant que l'état souverain la
souveraineté de notre peuple doit être
un inconditionnel nous avons beaucoup de
choses à faire nous avons beaucoup fait
nous avons cessé avec les situations où
le pouvoir était accaparé par des
pouvoirs oligarques il nous avons créé
des réserves et puissante qui stabilise
notre état sa capacité de défendre les
droits de l'homme et de défendre
l'économie nationale contre les
pressions extérieures et le temps est
venu de apporter des amendements dans la
loi fondamentale qui garantissent la
priorité de la constitution de russie
dans notre espace juridique
cela signifie ceci le droit
international et les accords
internationaux les décisions des
organismes internationaux doivent être
en vigueur sur le territoire russe
seulement dans le cas où il ne
contredisent pas à la constitution russe
et il ne contredisent pas à la garantie
des libertés et des droites et citoyen
russe deuxième je propose au niveau
constitutionnel
tu d'entériner les
critères pour les nominations des
personnes qui sont responsables pour la
sécurité et la responsabilité
il s'agit par exemple des responsables
des régions des députés le chef du
gouvernement les ministres les
responsables des différentes
institutions fédérales
ces gens là ne doivent pas avoir une
nationalité étrangère aux biens un
document qui leur permettent de résider
dans un autre pays un pays étranger le
soc la mission de la fonction publique
c'est le service et la personne qui ait
choisi cette voie je dois prendre une
décision lié sa vie à la russie à notre
peuple et pas autrement sans exception
[Applaudissements]
encore des critères strictes doivent
être valables pour la personne du
président russe le président russe
devrait rester sur le territoire russe
au moins durant vingt cinq ans et ne pas
avoir une nationalité étrangère non
seulement au moment des élections mais
aussi pendant toute sa vie je sais que
dans notre constitution
on peut voir là aussi y est de 7
ce nombre de mandat pour le président
russe je suis d'accord que le précédent
le russe ne devrait pas assumer ce
mandant
au delà de deux mandats il faut
successifs donc sur tout le territoire
russe pour obtenir ces résultats nous
devons lancer tous nos projets vous
connaissez bien sûr les problèmes dans
l'éducation dans la santé qui sont liées
à ce décalage entre le niveau fédéral et
le niveau régional du pouvoir qui a de
l'impact négatif pour les gens il y a
des droits et des obligations qui sont
égaux pour tous les citoyens
mais parfois il y aller juste us et qui
menace la stabilité de notre société
je ne je crois qu'il faut entériner les
critères unique du pouvoir public et
entériner ces principes dans la
constitution les compétences et les
possibilités de l'auto détermination de
l'administration locale devraient être
renforcées dans la constitution
et bien sûr tous les cas de figure les
obligations sociales devraient être
respectés de la part de l'état il faut
donc entériné dans la constitution
le montant du salaire minimum qui ne
devrait pas être inférieurs au minimum
vital
nous avons cette disposition dans le
hall mac mais il faut inscrire dans
cette disposition dans la constitution
et il faut entériner dans la
constitution les principes de retraite
par exemple
l'indexation des retraites 4e la russie
s'est
pays très vaste et chaque entité federer
a ses particularités il faut prendre en
compte ses particularités
il faut augmenter le rôle de gouverneur
dans la prise de décision au niveau
fédéral en l'an 2000
j'ai constitué le conseil d'état qui
réunit tous les gouverneurs ce conseil
d'état a fait preuve de son efficacité
ce groupe de travail qui garantit
l'examen très efficace des questions les
plus importantes il faut entériner dans
la constitution
le statut du conseil d'état
cinquièmement la société russe devient
plus mûre responsable et xix jantes les
forces politiques principale dans le
monde
malgré les diversités diversité adopte
une position patriotique et reflète la
position des électeurs presque tous les
groupes politiques dans la dos m'a dit
ah je vous savez que les responsables de
ces groupes politiques parlent toujours
avec le précédent sont prêtes à assumer
la responsabilité dans la formation du
gouvernement ce sont des
applaudissements qu'ai-je entendu mais
je pense qu'il vous allez devoir la
possibilité d'applaudir des niveaux
écoutez moins jusqu'à la fin
alors avec plusieurs instances des
responsabilités pour la formation du
gouvernement
ça signifie déçu mais la responsabilité
pour la politique qui sera menée par ce
gouvernement
moi je suis d'accord avec
cette position quelle est la situation
actuelle et conformément à l'article 111
et 112 de la constitution de la
fédération de russie
le président ne reçoit que l'accord de
la douma d'état pour créer pour
reconstituer le gouvernement et c'est le
président qui nomme le chef du cabinet
et tous les ministres je propose de
modifier cette procédure est confiée à
la demande et a non seulement la
concertation mais l'adaptation du la
candidature du plus un premier ministre
et ensuite à la proposition du premier
ministre a adopté les candidatures de
des ministres et les présidents sur a
obligé de les adapter au poste il n'aura
pas la possibilité de refuser au
parlement la nomination des candidats
qui ont été votées par les députés
tout cela concerne des modifications
importantes dans le système politique
jme je dois répéter que compte tenu de
la maturité de nos structures la
maturité de notre société
toutes ces mesures sont opportunes pour
renforcer le rôle des groupes
parlementaires pour renforcer
l'indépendance du premier ministre et
des tous les ministres ce qui peut
rendre plus efficace et la coopération
entre les branches législative et
exécutive du pouvoir à leurs chers
collègues je tiens à souligner que je
suis persuadé que notre fille compte
tenu de son territoire
énorme sa composition complexe du pont
de vaux territoriale et âme ationale
notre pays ne peut pas de se développer
ni rester en forme d'une république
parlementaire la russie doit rester
forte eric république présidentielle
alors le président doit garder son
autorité de déterminer les priorités de
l'activité nationale
il doit garder la possibilité de 10 me j
allais premier ministre à il doit garder
la possibilité de diriger directement
les forces armées et tous les systèmes
de maintien de l'ordre
à cet égard je propose de faire encore
une pas pour garantir l'équilibré entre
les branches du pouvoir
les 6e point je propose d'envisager que
le président pourra nommer les
dirigeants des services d'émission de
l'ordre après les consultations avec
l'assemblée fédérale
ce qui est en fort sera la transparence
de ces nominations
ce principe de consultation préalable
avec la à avec les députés peut-être
aussi adopter pour la nomination des
procureurs
chers collègues en pratique ça pourra
engendrer des obligations y compris les
obligations en formelle devant les
autorités locales il faut le prévoir les
consultations auprès du haut conseil de
fédération qui est représentant des
régions
c'est une mesure très efficace à montpon
du il faut pas tu connais des
différentes procédures dans différentes
régions puisque le procureur par exemple
elle représente le pouvoir public et de
supervision non obstant d à conditions
locales des régions
l'essentiel c'est que le procureur
protège les intérêts du citoyen où qu'il
habite
dans notre pays il faut que nous sommes
qui il faut qu'on soit guidé par les
intérêts des citoyens
c'était un point le rôle primordial à
assurer la protection des droits des
gens à appartient aux deux tribunaux il
faut assurer le professionnalisme des
magistrats et le confiance de la
population envers le système judiciaire
la loi est essentielle la constitution
doit protéger les juges leur
indépendance doit garantir leur
assujettissement uniquement à la
constitution et à la législation
fédérale il faut prévoir dans la
constitution la pop les pouvoirs or
offert aux députés de proposer le
licenciement des magistrats qui ont
commis des actes qui ne permettent pas
de garder le statut des magistrats
cette proposition est faite un vu la
pratique contemporain la pratique
moderne c'est ça ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui notre pour renforcer la
qualité de la législation nationale et
pour protéger décidé les intérêts des
sites payants je propose de renforcer le
rôle de cour constitutionnelle et
notamment lui offrir la possibilité de
vérifier la conformité à la constitution
des lois avant leur signature par le
chef de l'état on peut élargir le
pouvoir de la cour constitutionnelle
pour la vérification d'autres
loi aux niveaux fédéral et au niveau
régional chers collègues je me suis
aligné qui les propositions que j'ai
mentionné aujourd'hui ne sont pas
exhaustifs
je suis persuadé que les associations
ont leur mot à dire dans le domaine la
société en général tous les citoyens il
faut une discussion publique à ce sujet
mais en inaugurant ces discussions je
veux à l'udc en donner une orientation
pour vous montrer qu'ils sont les défis
auxquels sont confrontés chers collègues
pourront pas oublier l'état de l'épi du
pays après 1991 après l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique nous avons gardé nos
ambitions
oh bien sûr avec en fort potentiel
humain en potence portant une main
territoriale historiques et autres mais
nous avons hérité des menace
nous avons eu des menace de telle
envergure que city inimaginable
auparavant il aurait fallu y penser
alors maintenant en construisant notre
société de futures nous avons des
objectifs parfois contradictoires le
premier approche qui sont petits peuvent
paraître en compatibles alors il faut
qu'on crée un système fiable street en
vulnérables est stable à 50 compteur
extérieur qui est garantir et sans
condition la sécurité la souveraineté du
pays
mais ce système doit rester souple le
vif et a fait à se modifier compte tenu
des modifications dans le monde et est à
l'intérieur de la société vu son
développement permanent
le système qui assurerait le
remplacement aux deux
des dirigeants ces modifications est la
condition sine qua non de la
transformation profonde de la société
visant le son développement l'essentiel
c'est de garder l'orientation pour les
intérêts de la russie jusque là aussi
très important et je veux le souligner
que les amendements que nous allons
discuter ne n'entendent pas les
fondamentaux de la constitution et
peuvent être voté par le parlement dans
le cadre de la loi existante par le voix
de l'adoption des lois
constitutionnelles appropriée mais c'est
un nouvelle concerne la modification des
approches de l'activité et du pouvoir
législatif exécutif et à la justice et
je suppose organiser des votes des
citoyen russe concernant les
modifications apportées dans la
constitution
le pignon du peuple doit être
déterminante
c'est ce sont les gens qui vont décider
aujourd'hui maintenant et à l'avenir
pour les pour la stratégie du
développement et pour les conditions de
la vie quotidienne tout cela doit être
fait qu'avec le respect de l'opinion du
peuple l'année 2020 c'est une pub il
bifurqua science
la russie a devant elle des missions de
rupture démission historique est là pour
résoudre ces problèmes pour atteindre
ces objectifs la proche de chacun est
nécessaire
nous devons le faire un simple jeu le
sully et je le redis la russie c'est
nous il s'agit pas de nous qui sont
présents dans cette salle non
la russie se sont tous les citoyen de
autre pays je crois qu'une autre succès
sera garantie par notre belle volonté à
attendre des meilleurs objectifs
notre travail a pour notre famille pour
nos proches pour nos enfants pour leur
avenir
en fin de compte pour la grandeur de la
russie et pour la dignité de ses
citoyens je vous remercie de votre
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]